سنذكر بالخبر العاجل الذي ظهر على الشاشه
قبل قليل حيث اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه استشهاد ثلاثه فلسطينيين خلال
تبادل لاطلاق النار مع قوه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في جنين بالضفه الغربيه وقد
اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي ان قواته تقوم
حاليا بعمليه داخل المخيم بالمدينه
معنا من رام الله مراسله الجزيره جيفارا
البديري جيفارا ما الذي يجري في هذا
المخيم في جنين
نحن لا نتحدث عن المخيم نتحدث عن منطقه
رئيسيه وسط مدينه جنين في شارع يعرف بشارع
ابو بكر عمليه الاغتيال تم في هذه المنطقه
على الاقل وحده اسرائيليه خاصه قامت
باغتيال ثلاثه شبان ثلاثه مقاومين
فلسطينيين وفق شهود عيان وايضا وفق عدد من
المصادر الطبيه التي تحاول الوصول الى
المنطقه لان قوات الاحتلال بعد اكتشاف امر
الوحده الاسرائيليه الخاصه من قبل الاهالي
ومن ثم
ذهاب المقاومين الى تلك المنطقه قامت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بادخال تعزيزات عسكريه الى تلك المنطقه
حولتها الى منطقه عسكريه مغلقه هناك جنود
يتواجدون على اسطح عدد من البنايات ولا
يسمح لاحد بالوصول الى المنطقه التي تم
فيها اغتيال المقا الثلاثه هناك وفق بعض
المصادر وشهود الاعيان عدد من الجرحى ولكن
لا يوجد مصادر طبيه تؤكد ذلك اي مصادر
طبيه رسميه كوزاره الصحه تؤكد ذلك ولكن ما
نؤكده انه وحده اسرائيليه خاصه اختالت
هؤلاء المقاومين الثلاثه عندما نقول وحده
اسرائيليه خاصه اي من وحده اليمام او من
وحدات المستعربين هذا معناه انه لم يكن
هناك اصلا اطلاق او تبادل لاطلاق النار
لان وحدات المستعربين هي تدخل تختال ومن
ثم يتم دفع التعزيزات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه والشهود عيان اكدوا انه لم
يكن هناك اطلاق نار نتحدث عن شهود عين
كانوا يتواجدون حول المنطقه هم فقطوا فقط
سمعوا اصوات اطلاق نار من قبل قوات
اسرائيليه كانت تتواجد في هذه المنطقه
تفاجئوا بسماع هذا هذه الاصوات
للرشقات الناريه التي اطلقت وبعد ذلك
بدقائق اكتشفوا ان هناك
[موسيقى]
وفق عالمصادر الاوليه نعم هم ثلاثه
مقاومين لا زلنا ايضا بانتظار كما اكدت لك
بانتظار بيانات رسميه لان الوضع الان غايه
في التوتر المصادر تكون نوعا ما شحيحه
ولكن الجيش الاسرائيلي اكد في بيانه انه
يقوم الان بعمليه عسكريه في منطقه جنين
وبالتالي يبدو ان هذه العمليه قد تستغرق
المزيد من الوقت او قد تنتهي بسرعه ولكن
يبدو انها قد تستغرق مزيد من الوقت لان
هناك اشتباكات مسلحه عنيفه توصف حسب ما
اكده لنا عدد من الصحفيين وايضا شهود عيان
وايضا من الطواقم الطبيه الفلسطينيه بان
المقاومين
يستنفرون في كل المواقع وهناك اشتباكات
مسلحه بين المقاومين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي التي كما ذكرت حتى الان هي لا
زالت تغلق المنطقه
الكامل الان جاءنا تحديث جديد اسمح لي عبد
القادر من وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه كما ذكرت لك نحن نواصل التعامل
مع هذا اذا المؤكد الان ثلاث شهداء برصاص
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نتحدث عن ثلاث من
المقاومين على ما يبدو مستشفى جنين
الحكومي
يؤكد وجود اربع اصابات بالرصاص الحي
ومستشفى ابن سينا التخصصيه يتحدث عن اصابه
طفيفه بالرصاص الحي اذا حتى اللحظه ثلاثه
شهداء وخمسه جرحى
بالرصاص الحي وسالت هذه الاصابات الى على
الاقل مستشفيين في وسط مدينه جنين هو
مستشفى جنين الحكومي ومستشفى ابن سينا
التخصصي هنا يجب ان نذكر ونعيد سير
الاحداث التي تتصاعد في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه نذكر انه على الاقل في كل يوم
خميس هناك مجزره ترتكب بحق الفلسطينيين
الخميس الماضي في شبع جنوب جنين الخميس
الذي سبقه كان عمليه في نابلس قبله يعني
على الاقل كل يومين او ثلاثه هناك شهداء
يسقطون كنا نتحدث عن ارقام بسيطه الان
يمكن ان بانتظار يعني العدد النهائي من
وزاره الصحه لمجمل عدد الشهداء منذ بدايه
العام اي ما يقارب من شهرين ونصف نقول
اننا تجاوزنا تسعين شهيدا الان كتيبه جنين
وفق ما جاءنا من المصادر مؤكده
تؤكد استشهاد احد قادتها وهو مسؤول قوه
البهاء في كتيبه جنين لا استطيع الان ان
اذكر الاسم الافضل ان تريث بانتظار
معلومات من
المصادر الطبيه الفلسطينيه الرسميه